[Música]
hoy nos acompaña una escritora
colombiana boda además estamos hablando
de catalina navas catalina gracias por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 para mí es un gusto estar
comenzando aquí contigo el gusto es mío
muchas gracias catalina hablemos de esta
novela que estás presentando en esta
feria internacional del libro de la
ciudad de bogotá el movimiento en la
crisálida que es la crisálida porque se
llama así la novela y de qué se trata
por favor todas las cámaras son tuyas
para que le digas a nuestra audiencia de
qué se trata esta novela pues raúl la
crisálida es la etapa de la mariposa
previa a volverse un animal al lado es
lo que nosotros es el animal que está
dentro del capullo dentro de la pupa es
el animal que se reposa y a mí me
interesaba mucho esa etapa del animal
porque me parece que aunque parece
muerta realmente está como solamente
esperando y me gusta la idea de pensar
que incluso aunque está aparentemente
quieta se está moviendo por dentro
porque tiene un tiempo que hace que su
cuerpo se mueva y su cuerpo se mueva
esperando a convertirse en un animal al
lado entonces me gustaba mucho esa
dualidad entre movimiento y quietud de
qué se trata esta novela de catalina
esta novela es sobre la historia de
pedro caballero un muchacho clase media
de bogotá que vive en los 60-70 s en el
barrio carbó sur un barrio en el sur de
bogotá y que decide emigrar a eeuu
entonces digamos es una persona que no
le gustaba mucho su barrio tenía una
cierta incomodidad un poco como la
incomodidad que deben sentir tal vez las
orugas cuando están incómodas porque
sienten que deben transformarse en otra
cosa entonces se incómoda para buscar un
lugar encuentran un refugio y deciden
cambiar este personaje siente esa
incomodidad decide emigrar y cuando
llega a eeuu se da cuenta pues que ese
digamos ese camino ascendente ese sueño
americano que lo había imaginado no es
tal porque encuentra una serie de
barreras primer lugar la barrera del
idioma es una persona que aprende inglés
entonces llega a eeuu se da cuenta que
el inglés que tiene es un inglés
insuficiente es un idioma que no le
alcanza para percibir la realidad en
toda su complejidad pero tampoco para
comunicarse con libertad y bueno y son
los 80s y finales de los 70 s en eeuu
entonces está el virus del vih mi
protagonista es un hombre gay entonces
digamos que eso también es parte
importante de la trama del libro como
nació de la iniciativa hacer este libro
eres cercana con alguien parecido a este
personaje o con la comunidad del eje
vete y no soy por supuesto le digamos
soy cercana culturalmente la comunidad
del gtv pero este personaje es un
personaje que era el hermano de mi madre
el hermano de mi mamá murió en el año 90
y todos de complicaciones asociadas al
sida y yo después de haber crecido en
una familia que no mencionaba mucho el
nombre de la enfermedad para la que la
enfermedad así como para muchos
colombianos y latinoamericanos y mucha
gente era digamos un motivo de vergüenza
y de mantener ciertas historias en
secreto pues yo quise contar esta
historia también como una suerte de
homenaje póstumo
a mí me interesan los relatos familiares
me interesan los secretos familiares los
vacíos que hay en las historias que nos
cuentan nuestros mayores y me interesa
trabajar a partir de eso siempre es que
este libro a lo mejor puede ser una
liberación una catarsis para gente de tu
familia que no habla esta enfermedad que
no era tan cercana con tu tío que a lo
mejor se arrepintió de no compartir
tanto tiempo con él no sé raúl que
pregunta difícil me haces
curiosamente he recibido con los
comentarios de parte de mi familia yo
siento que lo que va a pasar es que no
no va no no por lo menos hasta ahora no
ha sido un detonante de conversaciones
abiertas familiares y sinceras creo que
lo que va a pasar es que estará allí y
será una conversación que se tenga un
poco en silencio pero no necesariamente
creo que vaya a servir veces era una
conversación que tal vez tengan en
solitario algunos de los miembros de mi
familia pero hasta ahora no ha sido
no diría yo que va a haber un gran
cambio en la manera como hablamos de la
enfermedad volvamos a la novela y
hablando de esta enfermedad de esta
epidemia del vih en los años 70 cómo se
vivía en esa época sobre todo en eeuu
donde estaba el protagonista de tu
novela así es pues yo trate de mi
personaje lo que siente es una gran
frustración porque el personaje siente
que debe emigrar a eeuu a raíz de unas
imágenes que ven en la televisión
entonces este personaje era un hombre
gay en los años 70 60 en colombia
donde en ese momento de la
homosexualidad estaba incluida en el
código penal entonces de repente ve unas
imágenes como de una marcha de orgullo
gay en eeuu y se le abre la cabeza y
dice cómo es posible la imagen que él ve
todas ahí hay mucho de diálogo con las
imágenes de archivo entonces ve unas
imágenes de unos hombres con el torso
desnudo con tirantes caminando
sonrientes en el sol y entonces él dice
esto es posible esto es posible como
habitar el espacio público con seguridad
y orgullo yo necesito irme de acá y
entonces hace todo para irse y tiene
como esta tal vez lo que sentirían los
pájaros cuando tienen que emigrar a
lugares más cálidos son las mariposas
cuando tienen que emigrar de un
continente a otro para buscar alimento
es un poco lo que le pasaba al personaje
tu personaje también catalina se
devuelve ya después de muchísimos años
creo que en el año 92 y decidas en el
libro a colombia que fue el que le
detonó eso a tu personaje para volver a
un país de donde se fue porque se sentía
algo más de alguna manera reprimido que
nos que no era parte de la porque
regresa es un exilio cultural él regresa
porque hace mucho también con las
personas que habían emigrado a eeuu por
ejemplo el movimiento de artistas de los
años 80s y 90s en colombia que habían
emigrado a parís a nueva york y que
volvieron a ser cuidados por sus
familias una vez enfermaron entonces el
regrese a hacer cuidado como en los
últimos años en los últimos días pero
pero también regresa a cuidar que era
una cosa que yo quería hacer en el libro
no es solamente como el personaje
aparece a recibir los cuidados de una
familia de la que él se fue sino que
también retoma unos lazos familiares y
afectivos y descubre también el cuidado
él como un cuidador no a pesar de su
enfermedad de su debilidad del deterioro
corporal pero él también descubre cómo
los lazos afectivos que no había
descubierto antes aquí el cuidado
cuidaba a su sobrina a su sobrina que es
una sobrina pequeña que debe tener
cuatro o cinco años para él para el
momento pues en el que él narra a pesar
de que no puede cuidarla como
activamente porque ya está débil de
cuerpo si las cuida desde el afecto como
de una de una relación de pequeños
gestos y como un cuidado cotidiano
decías catalina también que este
personaje el detonante para que se fuera
estaba unidos era unas imágenes en el
libro hay unos gráficos son muy bonitos
estos gráficos como como los hiciste
porque además fuiste la autora de estos
gráficos y a mí cuando cuando yo empecé
tuve esa idea de escribir este libro me
di cuenta que en mi casa había un
archivo fotográfico que mi tío había
dejado un archivo de cientos de fotos en
las que lo que teníamos era fotos de él
en sus viajes en eeuu en europa y empecé
a intervenirlas de la misma manera como
la ficción interviene el relato familiar
pues empecé a intervenir con plantas con
raíces con papeles
estas fotos que formaban parte del
archivo familiar
yo no tengo ningún talento artístico
plástico entonces me parecía que el
collage era una técnica que funcionaba
muy bien con mis escasas habilidades
artísticas hablabas que tu tío fue a
europa también en eeuu tu tío realmente
fue libre catalina tú creas que en algún
momento de su vida realmente encontró
esa libertad que tanto deseaba yo creo
que sí yo creo que yo creo que la
encontró uno no te sabría decir en qué
momento si en el exilio o si cuando
vuelve a ser cuidado por su familia pero
sin duda yo recuerdo por ejemplo
recuerdo cuando él volvía en las
navidades y recuerdo que era una persona
muy feliz así extática feliz de ser la
persona en la que se estaba convirtiendo
como sabes como ese orgullo que se
siente cuando uno es la persona que no
quiere ser yo eso lo vi en él
que le hice a estas personas que como tú
tibán la mejor tienen ese deseo de
libertad de ser quien uno es porque
realmente creo que es la esencia de la
vida no disfrutarla como no es las
personas lo quieren a uno por como uno
es y no estar como escondiéndose entre
capas y capas y capas tuve esta
experiencia personal que tuviste que
leería a estas personas que que todavía
tienen como como es como ese miedo tú
dices estamos en el 2022 es el siglo 21
claro y uno puede decir como pues puede
ser fácil pero pero todavía es muy
difícil para muchísimas personas no es
absolutamente
además hay unos asuntos también de clase
y raza
que no son fáciles es decir no es lo
mismo ser un hombre gay de clase alta
blanco que un hombre gay y negro
empobrecido no sé de todas esas
intersecciones también cuentan y hacen
más difícil la experiencia de
a construirse una sexualidad no
hegemónica pero yo diría que a pesar de
que mi experiencia supremamente
diferente soy una mujer heterosexual sin
género pero yo creo que no hay placer
más grande que en estos días lo decía
camila sosa en una entrevista también
que hacía en la biblioteca virgilio
barco y ella decía que no hay que hacer
más grande que mirarse al espejo en las
mañanas y sentir la alegría de saber que
uno se ha convertido en quien uno quiere
ser ese es un placer que yo también
experimentado a través de la escritura a
través de otras cosas en mi vida y de
verdad que estoy de acuerdo es como una
vez un experimenta el placer de siete
ser quien uno quiere ser no hay vuelta
atrás no hay vuelta atrás es verdad
tienes toda la razón catalina ya para
finalizar que buscas en un lector de tu
novela como cuando se termine de leer
qué sentimiento quisieras que los
lectores tengan raúl esta es una novela
llena de vacíos y es una novela porosa
en el sentido que hay muchas cosas que
no se cuentan por ejemplo esta es una
novela narrada en primera persona el
personaje no cuenta por ejemplo como de
vih es un personaje pues porque él mismo
lo dice y dice antes porque no es algo
de interés de quien me está leyendo
sabes y ese vacío todos esos vacíos que
están ahí son vacíos que el lector tiene
que completar y tiene que completar
desde que entienda por qué no se cuentan
las cosas o los tiene que completar
también con su propia experiencia es un
personaje que puede ser antipático para
muchas personas es un personaje que al
que tal vez para algunas personas que lo
lean para algunos lectores les pueda
parecer clasista misógino y lo es al
principio de la narración pero todos
esos huecos deben ser que siento que
aquí yo quisiera que fuera una novela
que el lector si fuera parte activa de
esta narración que separa transformando
a medida que la valiente y seguramente
va a ser así catalina muchísimas gracias
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de francés y 4 simple hacer
conversar contigo y sobre mente y sobre
todo es de la novela el movimiento en la
crisálida catalina muchísimas gracias
muchas gracias